miles de personas se concentraron en
berlín contra las medidas impuestas por
el gobierno para controlar los rebrotes
que aseguran han terminado con su
libertad mantienen que todo es una farsa
orquestada que el gobierno aprovecha
para obtener más poder aunque fue de
carácter pacífico la manifestación no
cumplió ninguna de las normas sanitarias
exigidas por las autoridades que habían
dado luz verde a la protesta y la
policía de la capital alemana se vio
obligada a intervenir y disolver lo
exijo por mí mismo la vuelta de mis
derechos básicos no en algún momento
sino ahora me exijo que se devuelvan mis
derechos básicos exijo la libertad de
expresión como la teníamos antes también
la libertad en los medios y un trabajo
periodístico libre nada de prensa
mentirosa quiero que volvamos a como
estábamos éramos una democracia y
despertamos en una dictadura
benedicto en parís el seguimiento fue
mucho menor pero el fin fue el mismo
protestar contra el uso obligatorio del
tapabocas y denunciar la posible
vacunación obligatoria que ellos
consideran dañina la policía rodeó a los
asistentes rápidamente
muchos fueron multados con 135 euros por
no llevar mascarillas
estoy aquí por el uso de mascarillas no
creo que sea correcto que sea un decreto
obligatorio el uso de máscaras también
provoca miedo terror y tal vez obliga a
la gente a aceptar la imposición de
vacunar para deshacerse del tapabocas no
quiero que la vacunación sea obligatoria
en reino unido- cientos de personas
también se reunieron en el centro de
londres para protestar contra las
medidas de boris johnson todo ello
cuando europa enfrenta el segundo
rebrote de la enfermedad que ya está
causando estragos